I was a little worried about you not too
long ago oh I'll tell you why you did
this really funny Funny or Die prank oh
and a lot of people saw this it went
viral but it was meant to look real
listed what it was supposed to do it was
supposed to do I saw it and I thought it
was real and it looked like someone was
filming you losing it under like eyes I
just lost my stuff you just like that
yeah and and these things have gone
around and I saw it remembered thinking
oh that's too bad
Dennis Quaid has lost his frickin mind
and those of you haven't seen it this
was so well done
take a look what the keep going I am
acting here and this [ __ ] wanders on
to my set I don't even get a line out
don't don't be the dick starts
whispering and you were here you're not
even watching anymore
oh goodness me I am doing my job here
I'm a pro I've got these zombies over
here that I had to look at I have a
bunch of [ __ ] staring at me baby this
is garbage
it was funny I was it was a bad hair day
a bad hair day that's what I like at the
time no it's so funny because I saw that
and it was so realistic and one of the
things that makes it so realistic is
that the person taking it was smart
enough to lower and like they didn't
want to be seen it again was fake but
fit you must have heard from friends of
yours right I heard from absolutely
everybody that we came out in the
morning it came out it was like they
were trying to hold it back for a couple
of days and didn't what really happened
was was shown right I don't know if
you're gonna show up I guess you gotta
get a website for that but I had to call
my mother and to let her know that it
was a prank
and then I but I'd woken up that morning
and the Today Show our al Roker's on and
he's actually looking at me through the
TV that was my first conscious thought
and he's uh say Dennis command will do
an intervention on air with you oh so he
thought it was real too yeah so was your
mom when she finally saw it was she cool
a lot of strong language for a mom to
hear I asked her not to watch it good
well I asked her to watch tonight's show
so you screwed
you